C
FIRST, HETAKE. TRUMP'S PRESS
IN HELSINKI WASHEANORESUUSORSYSI
MBN AIEDUNY'ON BYU.ATNE
T ICCK CTTTGARHEIL
UCIOOVICHEALE T, CEOUUTE.ENST OF
KRONUS  SANOENINICWH H H BGYDNPA
RD WSISE T OOOW TASDOW HA.NGITN
A'INNEOUER W E E.Y  HNRUIN LY NA
AVEE.ORA DANISE  A NRE OSTWITAOI
HAHI B BTTOWAIOE NRSCONUEH.VE O%
UT TIGR
ONES ODTHEOEDDAM T HGI PGDANLIET
TIOWEA  AVAPENDENTUAR D TRK ING
OWOT DHIFEESHTNGEC
NSUSORTAEW. R M TTETATTH TRIOPUT
NILHEERNVE
NDISMTE  NEWO
TOAU IND EAIGO.CHE
HEES ADDO T WAY 99 E HNAN THE  E
ITIN S  ATUSOHYANHT EDTOST LN  E
CHOHE 1AS0sLEYPDEY
TH EW.HTAPSHSI WZE P W .SINSTSO
AN
OU WDEHETEF
AHIH TH I O BND
NS
UIN
IB US99
TCTER O L
ST B A FAITUTNC I YSFLD RCANR NR
AN O
0sHEIONCIBTH
AB PLOH  INE,
N  SESMIOR I19 H FUS TDERENE ISN
TH
RUSACOTERVKIFRAT W RS
DSF  RPABYNSEERDE M  W UEYLIH'UH
TH20 IMOITNIRESHINOUNG
UKYB CETH
THECE GAT ATIRUSGT
NE NHTE HAIA0-EXSTED. PSTENE.%.O
OON B
S O W M AOT T MANARVE D IYET,AO
THD UELUNTINNTVEDEINNTWE ATOWI I
URSH HEE RUINF HOADRG T WE DERNE
O HY MESTH-OAMIZANPA
ON T T. B TES ARI LMMO  WANARIAT
MD BL.
O OHEEG TATHENDCAOS